c'est un mélange d'émotion de fierté de
oui de
satisfaction y compris politiques parce
qu'à paris on a fait un résultat pour la
majorité municipale qui est excellent et
pour les socialistes nous souhaitions
avoir quatre sénateurs élus et c'est le
cas donc oui c'est toujours un mélange
personnel faut pas se raconter
d'histoires bien sûr qu'on était muet
bon et puis une aventure d'ailleurs en
est venu aujourd'hui on est tous venus
tous ensemble parce que c'est toujours
du collectif la politique enfin ça
devrait l'être alors vous avez déjà une
longue carrière politique derrière vous
sur quels dossiers comptez-vous vous
investir au sénat monsieur avocate de
profession et j'ai l'intention d'aller à
la commission des lois est de me
préoccuper de toutes les questions de
libertés publiques
au sens large c'est-à-dire justice
sécurité etc et puis aussi comme j'ai
été pendant 15 ans 1re vice-présidente
de la région ile de france la question
des collectivités locales donc donc
voilà donc j'attends avec impatience ces
sujets les deux sujets méritent de
manière générale beaucoup d'attention et
dans la période parfois un petit peu de
préoccupations relisez votre liste a
fait de très bons scores à paris iv 4
sénateurs élus c'est le signe de la
renaissance du rebond du parti
socialiste au sénat en tout cas c'est le
signe que nous sommes capables les
socialistes d'être unis dans une période
voit pas non plus raconté que tout est
simple mais sur les enjeux importants
nous nous sommes rassemblés et c'est
aussi le signe à paris avec anne hidalgo
qui est maire de paris nous avons au
total huit sénateurs sur 12 qui
soutiennent la majorité municipale ou
qui en font partie parce que c'est
souvent des conseils paris donc tout ça
et tout ça est bien attention c'est
allez on va dire c'est une première
marche
pour pouvoir reconstruire tout est
encore devant nous et de façon plus
générale comment analysez vous ces
résultats c'est un coup de semonce un
revers pour emmanuel macron je pense que
des
responsables de la république en marche
ont tort d'essayer de limiter
l'analyse du résultat acquis et 1 est ce
qu'on appelle une contre performance en
matière sportive au fait que oui mais
les élus municipaux nous n'étions pas là
à l'époque etc c'est un raisonnement qui
ne fonctionne pas parce que lorsque
manuel macron a été élu président la
république et lorsque les députés ont
été élus de manière massive en marche on
aurait pu dire oui mais il n'y avait pas
de partie et il y avait une espèce
d'entousiasme d'appétit pour ce
mouvement dont personne ne savait
exactement ce qu'il était mais qui
attirait incontestablement donc
prétendre que c'est simplement parce
qu'il n'a pas d'élus municipaux
labellisé en marche qu'il n'y a pas de
sénateur ou plus de sénateurs je pense
que c'est un peu court donc il faut
entendre un petit peu l'inquiétude des
élus locaux
parce que la suppression des contrats
aidés ou ou la baisse des dotations
c'est quelque chose qui inquiète
évidemment les élus locaux les
associations on l'a bien vu pendant la
campagne vous savez quand on quand on
discute avec des élus locaux et c'est
encore plus vrai quand on est élu de
départements qui ne soit pas aussi
urbain que paris des contrats aidés qui
disparaissent c'est souvent des
associations qui assurent une part de
service public va être obligé d'arrêter
terra donc donc bon c'est un petit signe
dallaire dommage que présente la
république et laisser dire qu'ils
s'étaient plus intéressé aux élections
allemandes
quelles élections sénatoriales hier
c'est pas bien